We split the atom and we've walked on
the moon. We've built machines that can
move mountains and reroute rivers. So
why, with all of that, can't we just put
out a forest fire? It sounds like it
should be simple. Get enough water,
enough people, enough aircrafts, and put
it out. That's how we handle every other
fire, like a house fire or a car fire.
But every single year, we watch fires
that grow so large, so fast, that all of
that effort barely slows them down. So
what's actually going on here? Why does
a forest break the rule that fire is
something we control? Here's the short
answer. A wildfire isn't just a bigger
campfire. Past a certain size, it stops
being something that simply burns in a
forest and starts being a system that
runs on the forest. Humans have
controlled fire for something like
hundreds of thousands of years, and it's
arguably the first piece of technology
that we've ever mastered. We know how to
smother it, starve it of oxygen, cool it
down. And we do this instinctively, like
blowing out a candle or a closing a car
hood. So it is a fair question, why does
a forest suddenly break that pattern?
The instinct is to assume that it's just
a matter of scale. A forest fire is a
house fire, just bigger. So more trucks,
more planes, more water. But that
assumption is wrong in an important way.
It's not just bigger, it's a different
kind of problem. Because once a fire
gets large enough, the forest itself
stops being the fuel sitting passively
in its path. It becomes part of the
fire's machinery. Let's start simple.
Every fire needs three things: fuel,
oxygen, and heat. Remove any one and the
fire dies. That's the entire idea behind
a fire extinguisher.
A forest is fuel on a scale that's hard
to picture. Not just the trees, but dry
brush, fallen branches, needles, resin,
roots. Layers of it build up over years.
Burn a small amount of that fuel and you
get a campfire. Contained, predictable,
easy to put out. Burn a lot of it at
once and something changes. More fuel
means more heat. More heat doesn't just
make the fire bigger. It starts altering
the environment around it. The air, the
wind, the moisture in nearby trees that
would otherwise resist the burning. Up
to that point, the fire is just a thing
that is dependent on the weather,
subject to whatever the wind and air are
already doing that day. Past a certain
size, that relationship flips. The fire
stops just reacting to the weather, and
it starts creating its own. And here's
where it gets strange. Extremely hot air
rises fast. As it rises, it pulls the
air around it to replace it. That inrush
of air becomes wind, and that wind
doesn't just exist near the fire, it
feeds it, pushing more oxygen into the
flames and helping it spread even
faster. This is the point where
wildfires start doing things that seem
almost unbelievable. Embers will get
thrown kilometers ahead of the main
fire, starting new fires far from where
anyone's fighting. Fire whirls form,
spinning columns of flame, essentially
fire tornadoes. Towering clouds called
pyrocumulus form above the fire, made of
smoke, ash, and rising heat. And in the
most extreme cases, these clouds
generate their own lightning, a fire
creating the exact conditions that could
start another fire somewhere else. This
is the moment where fire stops being
passive. It becomes a loop that
reinforces itself, heat creating wind,
wind feeding heat, heat creating more
wind, and so on. At this point, the
obvious question is, "Fine, but why not
just throw more water at it? More
planes, more tankers, more crews?" Well,
because at this scale, water becomes
almost irrelevant to the whole system. A
firefighting aircraft can drop thousands
of liters, but that only covers a small
stretch of fire for a short time. On a
fire front that might be dozens of
kilometers wide, that's a drop in an
ocean. Worse, in extreme heat, water can
evaporate before it even reaches the
ground, and the fire itself can simply
move faster than crews can respond to
it, especially once it's generating its
own wind. So, firefighting at this scale
isn't really about extinguishing fire on
contact. It's about something more
strategic. Slow it down, contain its
edges, and protect the towns and
structures in its path, and wait for
rain, for a wind shift, for the fuel in
its path to run out.
It's less like putting out a candle and
more like managing a flood. But, here's
the part that flips the whole story.
Fire destroys forests, that much is
obvious. But, some forests didn't just
survive fire over thousands of years,
they evolved around it. Fire recycles
nutrients that would otherwise stay
locked in deadwood for decades, clears
out that undergrowth, opening space and
sunlight for new growth. Certain trees
have cones that only open and release
seeds when exposed to heat. And fire is
literally part of the reproduction,
which means the villain in this story
isn't fire itself. It's fire that's
become too large, too fast, and too
intense for the ecosystem to handle the
way it's supposed to do. And it's not
just plants that have adapted to the
fire. Some animals have learned to use
it. In parts of Australia, birds of
prey, species like black kites and
whistling kites, have been observed
picking up burning sticks from an active
wildfire and dropping them somewhere
else entirely. The result is a new fire
in a new patch of grass or brush. It
almost sounds too strange to be real,
but Aboriginal communities have
described this behavior for generations,
and now it's been documented by
researchers. The birds do it because a
fresh fire flushes out small animals,
insects, lizards, and rodents fleeing
the flames, which makes them incredibly
easy to catch. So, the fire isn't
something certain trees have adapted
around. Some animals have turned it into
a hunting strategy. If forests have
handled fire for millions of years, why
do modern wildfires feel like they're
becoming unmanageable?
It's rarely one cause. It's usually
three compounding on top of each other.
One.
There's more fuel than there should be.
For decades, the standard approach was
to suppress every fire immediately,
which sounds sensible, but it meant
small natural fires that would normally
clear out dead vegetation never
happened. Fuel just kept accumulating.
Two, a changing climate. Higher
temperatures dry out vegetation faster.
Longer dry seasons mean more time where
a single spark can ignite an enormous
stretch of dried-out fuel. And three,
human expansion. Decades ago, the edge
of a forest was mostly just forest.
Today, that edge is often a
neighborhood.
This zone, where homes and wild
vegetation meet directly with no buffer,
has a name, the wildland-urban
interface, and it's been growing fast.
People want to live closer to nature,
land near city gets expensive, and that
pushes new housing further into
fire-prone terrain. That creates two
problems at once.
First, more ignition sources, power
lines, vehicles, campfire equipment,
sitting in the exact landscape that's
primed to burn. Most wildfires near
populated areas are started by people,
not lightning. Secondly, once a fire
does start, there's simply more in its
path, homes, roads, infrastructures,
people who need to evacuate in time. So,
it's not only that fires are becoming
more intense, is that we've steadily
moved ourselves into the place where
that intensity does the most damage. And
none of these alone explain what we're
seeing. Together, though, they compound.
Which leads to the strangest solution of
all. If fuel build-up is part of the
problem, one of the most effective tools
is deliberately setting it on fire, on
purpose, under controlled conditions.
Controlled burns clear out the same dry
brush and fallen debris that would
otherwise feed an uncontrollable fire
later. Managed fire breaks remove fuel
in strategic strips, giving future fires
nowhere to spread. In some regions, land
managers are reintroducing the same
natural fire cycles that suppression
eliminated decades ago. The idea sounds
backward at first, but it isn't. A small
deliberate fire set under the right
conditions can be exactly what prevents
a massive unstoppable one. So, back to
the original question. If we can land on
the moon, why can't we just put out a
forest fire? Well, because past a
certain point, it isn't really a flame
anymore. It's a moving system built from
fuel, heat, wind, and weather. All
feeding into each other faster than any
amount of water can undo. And maybe
that's the real shift in thinking here.
The goal was never to eliminate the fire
completely. Forests don't need that, and
honestly, neither do we. The goal is to
understand it well enough to live
alongside it.